welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka a friendly
neighborhood spoiler man aka Tony stank
cuz I've been indoors for about a week
now anyway we have some brand new images
that have just hit the web that leaked
iron man's returned to the MCU and it
currently has the entire Marvel Universe
in a spin throughout this video I'm
gonna be breaking down the entire story
giving my thoughts on it and debunking a
lot of rumors that are flying about at
the moment there will be heavy spoilers
here in regards to several upcoming
Marvel projects so if you don't want
anything rune then this is your last
chance to back out before you have to
use the time stone make sure you
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day and please drop a thumbs
up if you're excited to see Robert
Downey jr. return without the way thank
you for clicking this let's get into our
breakdown of iron man's return to the
MCU ok so a benders endgame had a very
fitting exit for Tony Stark on a number
of levels not only did he save the
universe
he also sacrificed himself in a way that
showed the complete character journey
that had been on throughout the entirety
of the Infinity Saga Tony Stark
initially started off as a self-centered
billionaire but over the past decade
plus run of movies he became a true hero
that was willing to give it all up so
that others could live it really was an
incredible exit for the character but
since then there's been numerous reports
that he's in talks with marvel over a
potential return these rumors have gone
from saying that he'll be appearing in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness to stating that he will be the
voice of the AI in the rumored iron hot
series Downey himself came out and set
on the Joe Rogan podcast that it would
take a very unique set of circumstances
in order for him to return but it looks
like these are indeed in place as of
this morning images of leaked to the
Internet that show up behind-the-scenes
look at what will be happening with the
character going forward I can't post
these here because Disney like the DMCA
videos faster than Tanner snapped his
fingers however I posted them on my
Facebook page which is linked in the pin
comment so just scroll down click the
link to that and you should be able to
see the first look at Iron Man's return
and a couple of other cool pig bits that
we'll be discussing in the video we
posted leaked images on there all of the
time so if you want to see stuff before
anyone else
definitely make sure you join the group
anyway this concept art comes from an
upcoming what-if episode that will see
Ironman traveling to Sekar and becoming
one of the Grand Master's champions in
the images you can see that Ironman has
upgraded his armor to an almost
gladiator like level and it's equipped
with shields and a new type of weaponry
now we did have a tease about this a
couple of months ago from Jeff Goldblum
who let's slip that the actor would be
returning in an episode featuring his
character the Grandmaster when answering
fan questions for BuzzFeed the actor was
posed with the question as to whether
the Grandmaster would be returning in
the upcoming movie Thal up in Thunder
though he didn't stay whether he would
be making a return for this he did
mention that he would be reprising the
role in an upcoming project here's the
clip directly from the interview itself
so you can see all that he says then
we'll break down the comments and
discuss how things are going ahead in
the release hey we're we're talking
about it in fact you know I I hope so
I love Tiger ytg is a great director and
a friend of mine so I hope so but I
played the part again a couple of days
ago I went to the Disney Studios and I
recorded the grandmasters voice for an
episode of a show that's gonna be on
Disney Plus called what-if where it's an
animated version of all the characters
we know and love from Marvel and this
episode included the Grand Master and
Iron Man so Robert Downey will do a
voice in that and Korg Taika Waititi
will do had already recorded his voice
for that so yeah i enjoyed for a couple
hours i enjoyed doing that again so the
grand master is as well so you heard it
right out of the horse's mouth that
Robert Downey jr. will be reprising the
role however with these new leaks comes
a lot of new information according to
insiders the episode will pick up in the
wake of the Avengers right after Iron
Man has flown the nuke up into space in
the timeline we saw Tony return to earth
whilst the portal was collapsing however
in this new vision he doesn't make it
Tony then drifts off into space and
eventually he winds up once a car where
he scooped up by the Grand Master and
placed into the contest of
ian's now those are all the leaks on the
episode that we were able to get but it
is always good to hear that call will be
returning to you which jeff goldblum
seems to cement Tony will have to fight
tooth and nail as similar to how the
health did and it's possible that it
could end up going toe-to-toe with the
angry Green Giant and the climax of the
episode which air I'd absolutely love to
see another hot Busta fight because
that's one of my favorite action scenes
in the entire MCU punch his face and
punch his face in now that all other
room is floating about that we mentioned
earlier that stay the actor will be
returning is the voice of the AI in Hein
hardsuit you probably have seen he's
posted about and they're really starting
to pick up steam I do believe that these
are fake as the time that they were
posted Hollywood was in complete
lockdown and the only source that has
picked up on them is we got this covered
it tends to report things without any
factual basis and as no other trades
have picked this up especially when it's
a slow news yeah I can see being
truthful down you recently reiterated
that it would only be under some
incredible circumstances that he would
return and these interviews are more
recent than the ones which were recorded
by Goldblum back in November therefore I
think it's very unlikely with everything
in lockdown I know a lot of youtubers
are just jumping on these stories every
day but they rarely provide images or
links to their sources so you should
always take them with a pinch of salt I
do you believe that these current leaks
are true as they line up with what
Goldblum has stated and it also fits the
narrative in design they make a lot of
sense and if Sekar is where the
character ends up then having this
happen during one of the only instances
where is in space does seem to sell what
will likely happen we can't guarantee
these leaks until we see the show for
ourselves but based upon what we know
thus far they do make a lot of sense now
before we get into the rest of the video
which is gonna cover the other images
that were leaked I just want to let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
the Star Wars Skywalker saga box set to
one random subscriber all you have to do
to be in when the chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the leaks in
the comment section below that when it's
going to be chosen at random on the 15th
of April and the set will be shipped out
from the into ever gets the prize so
best of luck to everyone who takes part
now if you checked out the other post on
the Facebook group and you may have
noticed that there are
the images on there that shows CERN
elements from a number of what hip
episodes the second image shows a much
older Doctor Strange who has been
resigned to a walking stick according to
the leaks he is actually taken up the
mantle of the ancient one and is now
guarding the sanctum sanctorum long
after the events of Avengers endgame in
addition to this you can also see an
image of Steve Rogers flying an Iron Man
esque suit in World War 2 and this is
from the Peggy Carter episode which
tells the story of what would have
happened had she taken the Super Soldier
Serum instead of him so they are
definitely trying to bring Iron Man back
to the MCU in several ways from not only
costume nerds but also with the
character himself if you read the
graphic novel Planet Hulk then you'll
know that there are a ton of things that
can happen on Sircar and I definitely
want to see what Iron Man can do on the
planet
Sekar is a world that is far advanced
beyond ours and with this additional
technology it's gonna be really
interesting to see what modifications
the character can cook up and add to his
armor I also think that Robert Downey
jr. and Jeff Goldblum are an incredible
combination and I can't wait to see them
riffing back and forth on one another
Disney are driving a lot of people
towards Disney Plus right now and it's a
big focus for the company and makes
sense to get this level of cameos and
voice actors onboard and from the lineup
that we already know I think that Marvel
fans are in for a real treat when it
comes to it
overall I'm hyped to see the new
episodes release on the platform I think
it's the best possible way to bring him
back
it doesn't null and void his sacrifice
from the finale of endgame and it also
takes the character into a direction
that we haven't really seen before in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe now
whether the actor returns beyond this we
don't know yet
but personally I do kind of hope that
they keep him but specialized projects
like this instead of pulling them out
for an in the flash cameo I think it
kind of ruins the send-off that we got
and it's unneeded when they stuck the
landing so well within game that's just
my personal opinion on it but I do get
why other people just want more and more
of a good thing
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these leaks and if you're
excited for the show's going forward
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out a
breakdown of some of the insane details
that you miss in avengers endgame I
guarantee there's a lot in there that
peep
haven't picked up a pond so it's
definitely worth checking out after this
you want to support the channel Romans
let this ninety-nine cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and there's a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat us after
the show either follow a set definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below that was the best ways
to keep up to date with heavy spoilers
so hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]